This edition of the Scout Mash podcast is brought to you by the folks at Conahoe Creek Outfitters.
They know camping and they know scouts. They are scouts
And they know how to get you great gear and great prizes for all your camping adventures.
So go visit them at conahoecreakcom, at conohocreakcom.
And now the old scout master.
But I was sitting on a log in Neal California and a group of guys went by
And there was like six or seven of them
And the last guy went by and on his backpack. it was an external frame backpack.
It was the most weirdest looking sleeping bag I've ever seen
And I just glanced at it.
He's going by but he's going down the trail.
I said that's strange, looking
So fine. I couldn't resist.
I got up and I ran down the trail and got right up behind him.
I've seen a sleeping bag look like this.
It wasn't a sleeping bag,
It was a clear bag of Cheetos.
It was two feet wide and a foot and a half around, strapped where a sleeping bag goes,
And it was Cheetos.
Did he give you any?
No, I just turned around, shook my head and walked back.
I asked a couple of scouts. I said that we're sitting there with us on the log.
I said: did you see that kid?
They go, yeah, yeah, yeah, he's got a bunch of Cheetos.
I said you could see that.
They saw it immediately, the scouts,
And they were jealous.
So what's the story there?
I mean, he just likes Cheetos a lot, or
Wasn't in my troop?
Our troop was sitting on a log.
They walked by and it went off into the woods and never saw him again.
But he had, he had like three pounds of Cheetos.
That's a mystery,
That's a weird one.
Hey, this is podcast number 166..
Hey,
Well, welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green and we have one entry in the mail bag this week.
Let's have a listen.
Hi Clark,
This is Cameron Smith.
I am the scout master of maybe four months now of troop 51 here in
Minnesota, California.
I just wanted to call to let you know two things, both a review and a
little story.
So I'm in cubs, right,
And I know my son's going to be going to scouts because he's
legalized too
And I'm like, okay, well, they're going to want a leader,
They're going to need help.
You know, I know how this goes.
I'm going to get some training.
So I did all the training.
I go to leader specific training and I did all the online
training and I even went to Wood Badge.
Wood Badge was awesome.
Then I show up to the troop, fully fled, ready to go.
I want to be an assistant scout master with you guys
And they look at me and go: well, actually we have a scout master
who's kind of leading the position. now
What do you think about being the scout master?
So that's the end of the funny story.
I became the scout master
And next to Wood Badge, I have to say this podcast, this
program that you put on, is probably the most valuable
asset.
I have all the resources that you introduce on your
podcast, be it books, be it other podcasts, and all the
subjects you talk about are fantastic.
I wanted to also say that the path that you speak to
and relay information you get from other scout masters-
like Larry, that guy, awesome guy,
That's my story,
That's my review.
Don't stop.
And I just want to say thank you one more time.
Thank you so much, Cameron,
Thanks for being in touch,
Congratulations on stepping up and jumping into the
volcano of scout master ship.
I hope I can continue to be a good resource for you.
And hey, we're going to hear Larry, and we're going
to hear Tom a little bit later on because we have
the scout master panel discussion.
I want to remind you that our next scout circle
is coming up on April 14th-
That's a Sunday night.
It will be between 9 and 10 pm
Eastern Daylight Time and you'll be able to
find us at scoutsircleorg, and our friend, Kevin
Callen, author and canoe guide, will be with us
to discuss canoeing and canoe trips
On the blog. this past week we've been talking
about high adventure canoeing, kind of in
preparation for talking to Kevin.
Scout Circle is a live presentation
followed by a question and answer session,
so it's all about audience participation.
Put that on your calendar, won't you?
April 14th- that's a Sunday, between 9 and 10 pm
Eastern Standard Time- go to scoutsircleorg
to see the presentation and participate.
As I mentioned earlier in this podcast,
it's the scout master panel discussion
for April 2013..
Those of you who are long-time listeners
to the scout master podcast will note the
absence of our friend, Walter Underwood,
who was on a family vacation this week
So he wasn't able to participate with us,
but we look forward to him returning next month.
Have a good time out there, Walter.
So let's get started, shall we?
It's time for another
scout master panel discussion.
It's time once again
for another scout master panel discussion,
And there's three of us tonight.
We've got Larry Geiger down in Vera, Florida.
How are you doing, Larry?
Good evening Clark, doing good.
And I've got Tom Gillard down in Tolahoma, Tennessee.
Hey, Tom, Hi Clark, how are you?
I'm doing good.
It's springtime and the Weebelows
are joining troops everywhere
and we're getting ready to go camping
and having a good time.
You had a nice backpacking trip recently, Tom.
We did.
We took a four-day trip while the
scouts were on spring break,
at 32 miles. in my four days
It was really
thunderstorms and lightning and thunder
and cold and,
Yeah, it was really good.
What could be better?
I'm sure it's been cold down there in Florida too, Larry.
Yeah, last week it was chilly,
Chilly, being,
You know, in the 50s at night,
All right.
So listen, guys.
we've been talking for a little while
and the subject of evaluating
scoutmasters
and evaluating troops
and evaluating our program
came up.
What I'd like us to think about for this discussion
is what evaluation tools
are available to us,
who should be evaluating what
or who,
and why. this would be a useful thing
for us to do.
The job that the three of us know best
is being a scoutmaster.
Let's talk about that for a minute.
How does one evaluate
a scoutmaster?
Self-evaluation is
pretty tough. sometimes
You have to do like we're doing
and talk to other scoutmasters
or other people
and see if you're on the right track
and listen to different things.
but sometimes
you can be pretty rough on yourself.
Yeah, you know, I think you're right.
I think that can cut both ways.
Figuring out what you're trying to do
and whether you're doing it right
can be a good way
to start.
Larry, where does the
kind of objectivity come in?
Who do you talk to?
You're a scoutmaster. Who do you talk to?
How do you figure out if you're really
making the program click
or if you're missing out?
I look at it kind of programmatically.
Are we
doing the program?
I look at interaction with other leaders.
Some guys
get together- you know
scoutmasters in a district or a council
and they're in other. you know
wood badge and other things
and they hang around together
and I haven't had that as much
for whatever reason.
So I look at the program
programmatically: Are we doing
what I think
scouting is supposed to do?
And of course I come back
to our ideals and our values,
but also to that lead, train and inspire
younger scouts.
Are we teaching the older scouts
those leadership abilities?
Are we using the methods to do that
and kind of
evaluate each
method and each
part of the program?
and I tend
to do a lot of introspection
about that, you know. driving
back and forth to campouts, I'm thinking about
how do we do in the last camp out
and I review the whole camp out.
You know, how did the scouts do,
How did the adults do
in letting them do their own program?
So I guess
I do, or have done,
quite a bit of that kind of stuff.
I would suggest that
there are several tools out there
that can help us out.
What used to be the quality unit award
is now the journey to excellence.
I think the quality unit
is a good thing to help districts and council
maintain overall quality.
but if you're a scout master
that wants to really
affect scouts,
I think the journey to excellence is better.
but I don't think those tools
are going to take you
quite as far as you want to go.
They're an objective measurement
that you can use.
it's not the be all
and end all- The number of times
you go camping and the amount of advancement
you have and the number of
courts of honor and parents meetings
and things like that are definitely indicators
of a successful program.
If you have weak scores
and you start there, then that's a good thing.
It gives you a base number
for how you're doing
and where you need to improve
or where you're strongest.
And one of the familiar tools that we use,
train both adult and youth leaders in,
is the kind of stop, start,
continue technique, where you
evaluate what you're doing
and you figure out what you need to stop doing
and what you need to start doing
and what you ought to continue doing.
And that's kind of an ongoing process.
It's not necessarily something
you sit down and do intentionally all the time,
but it is one of those things,
like you said, Larry, when you're driving back
and forth, when you're thinking about the troop,
when you're thinking about
the way that you're doing the work,
I think that's also a good tool to use.
it's a good thing to have in the toolbox.
I've been scout master for mostly
I've been the one that everybody
looks to. Now I know that
in some troops occasionally there's
some older guys and people turn
and look at them and say: what do you think about that?
You know they have this continuum.
but the last two, I've been the guy
everybody turns around and goes, well, what's that all about?
How should we do that?
You know, and sometimes I cross
my eyes and go, oh no,
And then you just work through it.
but I've been the one
who was a scout that had read
the material that went to training
and some other stuff
in my background. so I got
that, you know. and Clark,
you're now one of those guys,
and so's Tom. you know everybody turns
and looks at you because you're the scout guy.
you know. You've got
the age. you've just been around
a while,
Right. One of the other tools
that figures into this
is leveraging the
experience of others. Yes,
You can talk with other scout leaders.
hopefully, what we're doing
as a part of having this discussion
and the broader idea of the podcast
and the blog and everything,
is trying to share those
experiences. I don't want to mention that
without saying that it's not
that we're smarter than everybody else.
we've just been around longer, Right.
We've tried things out that
we thought might be a good idea,
that didn't turn out to be such a good idea,
and we've found different
ways of doing things that do work
and
sometimes been surprised to go back
and look in the literature and say, well, it was there
all the time We should have. just,
we should have believed it the first time
we read it. Larry mentioned that he doesn't
have a lot of
interaction with the other troops
in the district or the council, but
I know you've got a very large
online presence, which
you know. that's another resource,
like you just said, Clark,
with this blog or with any of the other
the other stuff out there.
that's always good information
and that's true, Tom, but are you
really
reviewing how you're doing
in the eight methods
in the aims in the program?
how are your
scouts doing? It can come around
to that. I mean you can. you can pull different
ideas from people and
put them up against
those standards and see
how it, see where it falls
right. Scouting is
one of those places in the world that is
just replete with advice
and advisors and how
to do things Right. If you're a scout
master or you're a committee chair or an
assistant scout master or something like that,
how do you know you got it right? how do
you know that things are working? and we've said
that. well, there are some objective metrics
that are indicators. they're
not the gold standard that
you're absolutely doing things right,
because you can drive indicators rather
than doing program, and there's a difference.
who do you go to? how do you find out?
how do you get
any kind of objective evaluation
of what you're up to? Well, I have found
that in the past-
generally- not always,
but generally- my commissioner
hasn't, hasn't been
and wouldn't be a
real good resource for that.
not picking on commissioners, but
some of the commissioners I've had
coming into a meeting have been
about as clueless as a brand
new weeblos parent coming in
as to what's going on. If you don't
have an experienced
scout master, who's a commissioner,
I'm not sure. Well,
you had mentioned it earlier
but it's-
it's one of those
when the older scouts age out,
get eagle or
just age out, and then they come
back for a visit later on
in their life and you're still there
and they come back to see what's going on
and they tell you
that
this was a real meaning
to me at some point, that
they didn't get it when they were a kid,
but then they later
in life they saw what you were doing
and it took them a while,
but now you can be validated
a little bit that, yeah, you were doing,
doing a good job.
I mean, this is one of the advantages of hanging around
for a long, long time-
is that I've talked with guys who are now
well into adulthood and I've said:
tell me a little bit about what you remember
as your time in the troop and what-
what you thought was good and what you thought was bad,
and you know, and just have that kind
of general conversation and they've pointed out
some things that I've changed
and sometimes it's myself personally
and just my attitude or the way
that I look at things. it's
some good feedback one way or the other.
it's not as good as
a Monday night or weekly
feedback would be. It took years
to get there, Decades.
Another good evaluation tool are your
ears, Listening to the scouts.
we wouldn't give an 11 year old scout
a piece of paper and say: tell me what you would change
about scouting, because they have
relatively not a lot of an idea.
but I think if we
listen to them as they're out and around
and we listen to our older scouts
talk, sometimes that
can be a pretty good indication of
things that we maybe
need to think about a little bit. One
evaluation that can be fairly immediate
is moms. I think a cool
thing is to have parents in
the troop
talk to the new parents. Another
way, another tool
to evaluate is listening to parents.
sometimes that can be very difficult.
sometimes it can be very encouraging,
but you'll get a more objective
outsider view
of how things are going
and how things are being perceived.
I do listen to that because it can
be eye opening sometimes
and you always learn something.
you never turn down a chance to
change something. If the
scout masters doing his job correctly
and the older boys are
trained and are doing their job,
then the younger scouts-
there should be some
evidence that they see and feel that
they're not being picked on
but they and their buddies are
being helped and encouraged.
The scout master and the adults are saying,
oh, it's just your program
and just like, go, do whatever you want to do.
and you know you get this thing where
a click of older guys
is picking on the kids and
then they're not really doing their job,
training and guiding
those older scouts. and you can get
a feeling for that from the younger guys.
I don't think that it's the younger guys
evaluating the program or the scout master.
it's evaluating
the results of your leadership
and training of the troop
leadership. It's tricky
to figure out what you're saying, Larry,
because what you're trying
to do is listen
and observe and to hear things
without affecting
the thing that you're observing. If you're
in the room and everybody's acting
the way that they ought to act,
you know well that
that feels pretty good.
but if you're not in the room
and they're still
acting that way, Something's working,
you know, then you're.
you should be very pleased,
because that means they have gotten the message.
That's where being able to sit
back and watch them, like you say
somehow, is always
a lot of fun, because
you can see them interacting without
you being a real
nuisance to them. What we want is we want
honest behavior
from their own initiative rather
than it being coerced by our presence.
so let's
go back to where we started.
you're a scout master or a
committee chair or another
adult leader and you're trying to figure out
if you're doing your
work effectively. Let me
ask you this, fellas: what are
the signs that maybe
you're not getting it at all?
You think everything is going so
smoothly that you don't really need to change anything
and you're not worried about anything?
One of the watch signs in the past
has been what we call a 14 year old troop.
that basically means that
somewhere around 14 years old
guys check out. It's run by adults.
the scouts don't feel ownership.
they do the scouting thing
and go camping for a couple years-
they never take ownership-
and somewhere around 14
they check out. There's clues there.
if you're watching
that, you can tell
if you're getting it.
If you're not getting it, you don't see
that problem
coming arising.
Right, if you don't get it,
you don't get it. Yeah,
If you're listening to this
conversation and it's
making sense to you and you're
identifying with the idea of being
a little edgy or maybe a little bit
worried that you might not be getting it,
you're getting it,
You're getting it.
Yeah,
If you think that nothing should ever be changed
and that you're hitting on all eight cylinders
all the time, I mean I don't think
that, even after 30 years,
and I'm concerned about
getting too set in my ways, about things
being unapproachable so that people can't
tell me if they do see something that's wrong.
having that kind of open mind
and being teachable
is a pretty important aspect of it,
And I have two very strong committee people
right now and they are into
the program, they're on target.
but they totally disagree
with me on a couple things
and that's not bad, but I grip my teeth.
Yeah, I mean,
you know there's lots of different ways
to get a cup of coffee mate,
and as long as you end up with coffee,
most of them are just fine.
I know how that feels
and if they're doing something wrong I'll say something
if it's not scouting.
So you have some objective tools
that you can use, like the standards.
there's some metrics to look at
that indicate that
you know you're probably getting it.
there's leveraging the experience of other people.
who can
you know? you can bounce ideas
off of and concepts off of
and test them that way and say:
you know, is this the way that you do this
or does this sound like it's working?
we can listen to the
scouts themselves.
it's a little tricky to do,
but if we can listen to them
and we
can hear the way that they're treating
each other, that's an indication.
and we also have the parents.
being able to talk
to parents and listen to them
and to hear how things
are being perceived and maybe
what they hear from their boys
back home
is also a pretty important
piece of the puzzle.
So thanks very much for joining us for this
edition of the Scout Master Panel Discussion.
Let's thanks, Larry. You're welcome, Clark. It's been great.
Thank you, Tom. You're welcome too, Clark.
Well, thanks
for listening to this edition
of the Scout Master Podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch:
Read the Scout Master Blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and while you do,
you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can also subscribe to the Scout Master Podcast
on iTunes and
access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you get details about how to make that happen
at Stitchercom.
You can experience all the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
That's right. Follow us at
Scout Master Blog on Facebook.
We tweet at Scout Master CG
on Twitter and, for admittance
to the exclusive Scout Master CG circle,
search for Scout Master CG
on Google Plus.
And if all else fails, of course, there's
good old email. That's right.
Zoom into the 90s and email
clarkgreen your comments and questions
at clarkclarke
at scoutmastercgcom.
That's clarkclarke
The Scout Master Blog
and the Scout Master Podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they in any way
endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
It's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and having a little bit of fun along the way.
Before we leave you, let's hear from
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pel.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why, thank you, sir?
Until next time.
Thank you.